I've been using these little headphone things
for about a month now.
I wanted to try them out for a long time
before I gave a review.
And, you guys,
you need one of these.
These are so cheap.
They work so well.
The battery lasts such a long time on them.
I just love using them as a backup for when my, you know,
more expensive ones die.
I just pull out these and,
um, use them.
I also use them for when I'm, like,
cleaning the house
and I wanna just put,
you know, one in my ear and listen to, like,
a podcast or something. Um,
they're just awesome ever.
I'm telling you,
go get these for, like,
your friends or whoever.
They're so little.
They're so cute and perfect to just have around.